comics really like the show I'm dying up
here yeah comics like it people in the
business which I'm actually surprised
that I'm not surprised but when we were
filming a definite thing I thought about
the most you know what I'm talking about
if you're on like a [ __ ] show you have
to walk around the Comedy Store and then
people are just looking at you like well
do you know what sometimes nowadays they
don't even know you're on that [ __ ] show
nobody nobody watches it up and they go
what do you been up to what people been
watching this and I'm really I feel good
about what people have been saying yeah
I'm proud of the show I think it's great
you know I hope we get a second season
so we can continue to develop the
characters but it's pretty cool
yeah that's cool congratulations man no
love but it's pretty cool well you know
what
I shot loved this morning and I was it
it was okay but why do they [ __ ] do
like 5:00 a.m. call times I have no idea
how about this have you ever had the 5vm
call time and then you're not on set
till like 11:30 or some [ __ ] oh dude oh
I did a [ __ ] the jeno skins right
they're like a prank
Australian on YouTube youtubers they
have a movie coming out lines about to
say you you dad you wait for a YouTube
[ __ ] like people are really I don't know
but they did a movie right mm-hmm and
they [ __ ] called me in at what 6 p.m.
now it's 8:00 in the morning you haven't
I haven't done anything I'm sitting I'm
like a zombie and I'm gonna give it to
there's veins in my head check this out
you're not gonna believe this okay I get
a knock from this dainty little you know
PA girl they send you home she goes hi
we're way behind so we're not gonna be
using I go [ __ ]
geez I'll strangle you with my [ __ ] a
little yellow hand I will [ __ ]
strangle the life out of your little
[ __ ] white [ __ ] body I [ __ ]
hate you right now I was livid of course
livid
I mean I I this is where I can't stand
to like you do like guest stars and
stuff like I did blunt talk you know
Patrick Stewart do you in that they were
horrible about like time but you you get
have 6:00 a.m. call and you don't go
into like 5 6 o'clock and then you get
in that top of show rape so you're doing
the same amount of work as a series
regular making 6 times the amount of
money you're making but you're doing the
same amount of thing it's some weird we
got a union have you don't even [ __ ]
know how much I love
Stuart he's the best now I just stop for
a second you know people don't know this
about me but I'm a next-gen freak really
I love and Star Trek next generation
that's the only Star Trek I like I love
data
I love Geordi LaForge I love Deanna Troi
I love [ __ ] Wesley Crusher you know I
love the whole thing and if I met
Patrick Stewart dude I would probably
stick my can email him is he gay he's
okay no he's got like eight wives yeah
yeah kind of gotta get married and
leaves him is he nice he's a great guy
but I got emailed him after Logan and he
got right back to me he was like well
yeah he's like a cool dude he'll get
back to you if I call my email and be
like Bobby Lee from the distant now he's
a big fan of yours Helen Hong and I were
on the show together okay who not Ali
Wong I see how you King bong way to law
we're both huge star track fans to Jack
so we're there and I'm like she's
sitting there with I here's Patrick
Stewart what's his name to place data I
love Helen by the line they're both
sitting right here together
too late now you're traffic no I love
her is us and I just go I'll pull out my
phone and go hey let's take a picture
because her and I are like I'm Worf and
she's like you know she's were the
people that died and then we were just
like having such a good time like what I
mean him taunt stop why oh I don't know
because you know you you call you look
at people's faces and then you match him
according to what you think they would
be in the Star Trek pretty odd my
girlfriend definitely romneyís Romulan
she's right oh yeah we're gonna forehead
for sure their forehead and I have the
nose eyebrows what does him yell a
Gilbert is definitely I would have to
say gay Klingon
okay that's specifically gay Queen yeah
you because they're not big yeah I mean
you're not big but the I yeah
get Klingon yeah is a very you know they
didn't make it
he's an Android but they didn't make him
right yeah like you don't mean like they
made a mistake Mauro's alien androids
you know aliens kills everybody raah
yeah he's like that he's not in that
generation the first generation first
definitely made a lot of mistakes with
this one and he's yeah he's still
Richard Ramirez he's like working in the
Jefferies tubes you know man like you
know and I'm definitely a Ferengi
rankings you know this it's a weird race
but they're like um Google Ferengi and
show it to him it's not a company you
spell that I was gonna say more like a
Fathead Borg you know oh that's a good
one
but well you see Ferengi then you'll go
oh yeah that's it speaking of Ferengi is
you were at my brother's house yes and
you need okay I don't understand how you
could be his brother
you were so successful and you have him
living like a peasant right now okay he
needs to do you need to get a house move
into a goddamn house
alright so you can have a video game
room far away from her so she could
sleep yes yeah and then and then he
needs to move into here because actually
my brother used to be Indiana Jones just
to find his apartment all right you know
the folders the boulders like snakes
right right it's really scared my
brother pretty sure you're afraid I'm
Frankie for sure and he looks like a
Ferengi that's doing a podcast yeah yeah
well my brother when he first moved here
from Arizona we went to ASU right he
stayed there he did great nine years oh
yeah
and hotel management he [ __ ] that was
his degree we are home we did he get his
degree yeah you would think in his place
would be more like piano in there he's
extremely neat though which is okay
given how much how many things he and
have limited space so he has his AC in
his bathroom I think blows why you pee
yeah he's got the AC he's got a hot
plate also in the bathroom but you don't
say that for a guy with no job not sure
it's fine how does he not have a job
he's a survivor like me Murph moved to
LA from ASU I lived in Silver Lake in
like a two-bedroom apartment with my
friend kalisto we man we lived with us
sometime oh wow yeah that's how I know
and my brother goes I'm gonna live here
with you I go great I had a little
closet
he went in stole bamboo from Home Depot
and he made his own little thing in the
closet like a bamboo like double storey
apartment inside the [ __ ] class oh
hold on
you had him living like Harry Potter in
the cupboard under the stairs
yeah he's the Dursleys that's what yeah
but he loved it there he listened yeah
this is why when I him and I were
talking about how his girlfriend you
know she's trying to change him and I'm
like hey [ __ ] like you knew when you
walked in his apartment who he was yeah
you don't change him now yeah it's like
but it's like when you're dating a
stripper and you're like I don't what
you stripping anymore it's like this is
how you met me